[Music]
my son-in-law threw a grenade into the
middle of trust i had in him with
infidelity and i'm struggling with how
to handle a conversation do i have a
conversation do i not have a
conversation thank you for being the
single most mature mother-in-law i think
i've ever talked to on this show
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone show
man i'm glad you're with us today
talking about relationships and mental
health and
whatever else is going on in your world
whatever's going on in your world you
want to be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291
it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to johndaloni.com
ask
and don't forget to call or write your
local congressman for my hot topic um
bill i'd like to introduce that you
can't you can't buy clothes at hot topic
and wear them in public if you're over
what did i say 25 will make up an age 19
19
that's probably good
yeah if you're yeah
i think that's i think that's wise all
right let's go to mary in little rock
hey mary what's up
hey john long time listener first time
caller how are you nobody ever says that
that's fantastic
are you serious i figured a lot of
people say that no it's because i don't
have any longtime listeners
they listen once they're like i'm never
listening to that stupid show again yeah
how are you
i'm good i'm good so what's up for
taking my call today let's save the
world okay so i'll
all right i'm gonna get in i'm gonna
give a really brief question and we can
kind of dig into it if you want to or
you may have a really brief answer so
here we go um my question is how can i
be supportive
of my husband's hobbies
without feeling kind of resentful
without the fact that they mainly take
him you know away on the weekends to do
stuff
ooh good question
uh okay tell me
more so we
have been married almost three years
we've got two kids under two um we both
work very intense full-time jobs his job
uh he has kind of erratic hours so he's
not home a lot at nights and some
weekends anyway and so that's why i kind
of put so much emphasis on our quality
time on the weekends and then
you know every few months it's like hey
i'm gonna pick up this new hobby and i'm
like why what are you doing anyway
um
okay there's a few things at play here
okay
let's see one
two kids two and under
right
or two kids under two right
yes okay
y'all are in a season
that is not gonna last forever okay
all right so i want you to like
let that be the sidewalk that we're
gonna walk on together um this season
will pass okay
the second thing is i want to hear from
you about quality time when you talk to
your husband about quality time tell me
how that conversation goes
i mean when i say like i think we need
to spend more time together it's doing
stuff as a family and
it's not
being in the same room while he's on his
phone or you know while i'm entertaining
our kids like i really try like i try
and explain what quality time means to
me and i don't always feel like that get
hurt i guess
okay
so
i'm gonna put that i'm making myself a
little note here so i can circle back to
it okay tell me about his hobbies what
are we talking about here
uh hunting fishing
all the things that go along with those
mainly hunting and fishing so you're
we're in the summer here so we're
getting to the end of fishing i'm about
to start the hunting season and you're
already anticipating losing him for the
next few months right
well i mean i try to be understanding
about certain seasons of hunting because
it's you know it's seasonal and i know
it's only a certain period of days where
he can do certain hunting and i'm like
okay but
for example a few months ago he traded
some piece of hunting equipment for a
fishing kayak and then it became well
i'm gonna go fishing every weekend in
this new fishing kayak
so
so tell me
there's something beneath the time thing
here
what is it
what do you mean
um
he makes declarations and switches
hobbies with some regularity
so is it the spending that's driving you
crazy or is it no no it's not okay is it
the perception that
you're stuck at home like
you could say i'm just going to go
kayaking every weekend but you are
looking at these two little kids and you
think i can't i'm here
and is it the freedom that he feels like
he has to just head out is that the
result
resentment
i think that's what it is and it's not
it's not that i have all these hobbies
that i want to be doing because you know
i love spending time with my kids
especially since i don't see them much
during the week but
i think it's the freedom yes if he can
say well i'm gonna go do this today and
i'm like okay i guess you're going to do
that today
but but
the resentment there is
and it's a common it's a common
resentment it's not that well yeah you
said it perfectly it's not like you want
to be out hunting
it's that
you want him to
want to
fulfill your picture of what a saturday
would look like
here's two incredible things okay
number one my guess is and you could say
john you are wrong we are good at this
if you're good at it you would be in the
one percent of the one percent okay of
married couples with two kids two and
two and under
is
have you heard me talk about pictures
and words here
yes okay
is that you have my listener come on
okay you have a very clear picture in
your head of what
time is with family family time looks
like
and
that we're not doing a great job of
communicating that to your husband
and he has a very clear understanding of
here's what i need
and he
communicates that with i'm going to go
kayaking every day because my guest is
kayaking or getting out in nature
whatever the thing is also fuels a
couple of things for him number one he
has two kids uh two and under and he
feels like he's lost his wife
number two he's got two kids two and
under and
he loves his kids with all of his heart
but he's got some skills that he doesn't
understand and so it's natural to want
to lean into the things that i'm good at
i i know how to hide in the woods and
shoot a deer i do not know how to
entertain a seven month old
and without some intentionality i'm just
going to
lean this away and if this hobby doesn't
fulfill it i'll find this one and this
one i'll fulfill all we're doing is just
trying to find something that's gonna
fill that gap
and
now we're just talking past each other
my guess is he would want more than
anything in the world is to be a
participant in
the life of his wife and kids
and
being out in nature going out and
exhaling and finding past hobbies and
things like that are really important
for people so it's twofold you need to
find some hobbies
okay and you all need to come to terms
with hey so i'm a big hunter i'm out i
don't talk about a lot cause i know it's
people don't like it um yeah i'm out in
the woods a lot a lot a lot and this
past fall i traveled all over
and so my wife and i had some
conversation like
like here's what i need i can't i i need
you your presence here
and i need she's got things that she
likes to do so i need to go do my
hobbies too and so i had to make peace
with i'm on the road a lot so the time
i'm gonna spend in the woods is gonna be
less this year but it's a conversation
we we had together but it was very
needs-based not i need you here just
sitting on the couch no no right i need
your son and daughter neither daddy
and here's what that looks like and
i need you to be on the floor with us i
need you to be here for four hours
because i need to go
do some hiking on my own right
instead of saying well you get to do
this and i get to do that and so now i'm
just pissed off and i'm mad at you you
know what i mean because then it becomes
about the hobby and the hobby is not the
issue the issue is i've got a picture of
what this weekend's going to look like
and you have a picture of the week is
going to look like and now we're just
talking past each other
does that make sense i think so yep that
makes perfect and all of that on top of
your body's a human jungle gym
nobody's sleeping and you're working
he's
probably not made the adjustment like
most most most young dads don't make the
adjustment on
your domestic responsibilities increase
50
i need you here and here's what i need
from you here's what this looks like
and so having a conversation about what
needs look like and y'all have to do
that probably every month or two because
they're going to change these kids are
going to change like crazy
is that hard can he hear that
yeah yeah i mean i understand what
you're saying yeah but you don't like
that tell me we don't like it no no no
it's not that i like it it's a it's a
communication thing that that we need to
work on i mean i see what you're saying
but i hadn't really i had been focusing
so much on the actual hobby
but i don't think i was looking i was
you know zooming out and looking at
maybe it's not
the fact that he does x or y it's the
idea behind why he's doing it so i think
i think that makes sense let me say it
this way
um
there's a like
him walking in all gross and dirty and
stinky
covered in camouflage whatever
at dark and he had said he's gonna be
back at two or three and he gets back at
dark
and
you're mad and you start telling
yourself stories about being mad and
what he's doing out there and he doesn't
appreciate all the crap you do and you
work a job like you're right so the
story machine is running and he gets
home and you're like i can't no more
hunting no more
there's that
and then there's a
tuesday evening after the kids are down
and you'll exhale and you have a weekly
what's our picture look like for this
week meeting
and you look at him across the table and
say i miss you
i miss you
and everything in our world has blown up
it's all different it's good but it's
all different now
and i'm tired you're tired we're both
working really hard
uh i miss you
and we gotta rebuild something new we
gotta recreate something new because a
human's multiple human bombs have gone
off in our home and so we're going to
we're going to rebuild something new
that's a totally different conversation
because it will eventually get to
the story i tell myself is every free
moment you have you'd rather spend it
not with us
that is the story i don't know right but
if you tell him you'd rather be hunting
than being with your kids
now i'm lobbing grenades if you tell
them the story i'm telling myself is you
would rather be sitting in the woods
covered in a dead animal's blood than
holding your kids
that's the story you're telling and
that's a much different approach
one of those turns him on his default
setting and he's going to get he's going
to get
sunday dad grumpy right
um or he's going to get angry and yell
which one is he yeah
uh angry in y'all okay yeah yeah
uh hey
you're always yelling around here no no
no
hey it scares me when you yell
see the difference there it makes me
feel unsafe when you yell and scream
like a child in the house
i'd much rather you go for a walk and
then come back and say hey uh here's
what i'm struggling with or wrestling
with
those two approaches get to the same
issue but one is a path of war and one
is a path of hey help me out here
because i don't feel safe or the story i
tell myself i'm taking ownership of this
see the big difference there
i do okay and there's a big difference
you're right yeah i see it i find that
it helps me
to write things down before i enter into
a conversation with my wife on these
topics
um
a good example happened just yesterday
and by the way
the more we make these regular
occurrences the better our relationships
get
um
kelly and i and joanna who works in pr
here we did a quick um
like
28 hour trip 36 hour trip to california
which is two time zones out right it's a
long trip
um we had an incredible experience with
the mind pump guys and we're we'll have
some shows coming out about that later
on but great trip the trip was awesome
and as we were coming back we got home
at 4 a.m when i rolled in
and i had a picture in my head of what
homecoming was gonna look like it's a
hundred percent a story i told myself
made up the whole thing
and then it didn't happen
and my wife my daughter's going to art
camp and my wife was getting her ready
and it just didn't happen in the way i
had pictured in my head
and then i started getting defensive
about it and then all of a sudden i find
myself getting mad like i just not mad
like not yelling but i feel mad in my
chest like
man
and then i had to pull the thread on
that very quickly and it was
oh yeah i told myself a story about what
um homecoming was gonna look like and it
doesn't look like that okay
and then i can grieve it real quick and
be like man
and then
my wife and i are gonna have our weekly
meeting and i can say hey this fall when
i'm traveling
here's what homecoming like i get these
pictures in my head
of what this looks like and then i feel
like it so i can take ownership of this
and realize that she didn't do anything
to make me mad my wife didn't my
daughter didn't my dogs didn't the
chickens didn't i owned the whole
narrative walking into this
and in this case maybe he is
like i've got friends who are hunters
and fishers fishermen that
they disappear it's their mistress it's
they cheat on their spouse with their
hobbies or playing guitar or whatever
the thing is
um i get that
and that's a hard conversation that
everybody's got to have but it's always
better done better with the story i'm
choosing to tell myself is this that's a
great entry point versus
if you go hot right
and man mary it's lucky to have you it's
lucky to have you we'll be right back
hey dr john deloney here and it's that
time again school is back summer is
winding down and it's time to get back
to the routines we threw out the window
back in may pick up drop off get up
early no more ice cream for dinner on
most days your schedules are probably
about to go bonkers but i've got a
reminder for you
for the love of all that is good make
sure you prioritize sleep for your kids
for your marriage for your job
for you getting seven to nine hours of
deep rejuvenating sleep is one of the
best things you can do for your health
not doom scrolling on instagram or
zoning out with netflix all night we all
need sleep and for me good sleep starts
with a great mattress and that's why i
love dreamcloud mattresses and right now
dreamcloud is making it easy with a
great deal just for our listeners
599 dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of 849 in accessories and savings i'm
talking pillows a mattress protector and
luxury sheets to go along with a great
mattress so go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloney to get your new
mattress today
all right we're back let's go to
becky in austin texas what's up becky
and austin
hey dr john just setting down the bricks
all right here we go
what did you sit down
hello you know i have been following you
from the beginning you and a.o talking
about what your podcast name was going
to be and
you and your team have just helped me so
tremendously with personal growth so
hats off to you guys you have a guest
thank you so much
the purpose of my call today um
my son-in-law of two and a half years
threw a grenade into the middle of trust
i had in him with infidelity oh and i'm
struggling you cheated on your daughter
yeah
and i'm struggling
with how to handle a conversation do i
have a conversation do i not have a
conversation i know that it's
it's their thing and i'm not in it
um i've shared with my daughter quite a
few of your podcast segments um
explained to her
after i mean i was just so mad i'm so
mad
and
she was devastated i was devastated but
you know i said these things happen and
it's part of life and you can grow past
it you can grow together
but he's sick and he needs some help and
she she knows that and he knows that
um
and i haven't seen him and i knew at the
time i was so mad don't talk text or
type man just say stay away because i
didn't want to say the wrong thing um
but i i'm gonna see him you know and i
don't want it to be where it's this
elephant in the room that no one talks
about
but at the same time i don't think
there's anything i can tell him that he
doesn't already know
i don't want to lay
guilt and shame and i just don't know
how i don't know how to approach it oh
man well thank you for being here thank
you for being the single most mature
mother-in-law i think i've ever talked
to on the show yeah it's incredible
it's because of you yeah right
no there's a lot of mature mother laws
that call but like your wisdom here is
incredible it's just incredible thank
you um
i'm trying to think of where to start
here relatively like i i instantly know
where i want to go with this but i want
to circle around it just for a second um
what was your relationship with this
with this young man before this
um
you know
they they were together for about a year
before they got engaged
he was not from our from our town the
area where we live so i didn't know him
i did not know his family
i've noticed
you know he's always welcome in my home
um
i felt like i had a good relationship
with him but i noticed
that i i think he was uncomfortable ever
being in the same room with me by
himself okay
i noticed that if it you know if my
daughter left to go they have a they
have a little toddler um
if she went to go ten to the baby he he
would get up and kind of follow her
and i always would ask him how's your
work you know how's your family just
kind of you know scratching the surface
and just general conversation but no
in-depth deep conversation with him ever
i know
he's had a lot of issues growing up and
his family lots of dysfunction um
with this same infidelity issue so i'm
kind of connecting all the dots
he knows it's wrong
he swore he would never do it and then
he did you know and i'm like okay
yeah um
so the only relationship you can
impact is your relationship with him
and so i i want you to spend your energy
not trying to fix their marriage or to
become a marriage
like have a radar for their marriage
they're going to have to figure that out
i also think it's wise at some point and
this is gonna be really tough
um
for your daughter to have another
confidant other than her mom when it
comes to deep marital issues
yeah and i just to speak to that she um
she texted me he
he's working like five hours away
and she texts me out of the blue and
said hey can you watch the baby this
weekend i'm like what what's going on
and she said well i just i need to go
you know i need to go
see my husband
and
but she wouldn't say well and it's very
uncharacteristic for her just at the
last minute hey can you watch him i
gotta go and so i called her and
she was balling and she you know so i
just kind of walked right into it it's
not
otherwise i don't think she would have
told me um
yeah she she did not has not told her
dad because she's afraid of the
repercussions on that side but um
anyway but you're yeah i understand
where you're coming from and she has not
mentioned anything since about and i
haven't asked i know have y'all gotten
help has all seen it i just
are you assuming that she's staying in
the marriage
i'm yes
it seems to me that they're working on
it
they want to get with better help you
know and he have a counselor and she has
a counselor action speaks louder than
words sure although you know we'll see
how that how that plays out but yeah i
believe she's putting forth her best
effort to try to work through it okay um
last question before i start walking
into it have you and your husband dealt
with infidelity of course across your
marriage
um
we've been we've been divorced for 12
years when we were married no um
no
not
my on my family my parents yes i have
lived through that so i think that's why
it's such a
poor subject for me you know
yeah
okay so
i'm assuming that they are working this
thing out
and that at this point your daughter has
the one that you feel confident you
raised wells good young moms got a good
head on her shoulder that she has looked
at this situation in her life and said
this is a relationship that i want to
continue to invest in good for her okay
um
any sort of trying to get in between
that her and that decision
um
i don't it's just an opportunity to
drive a wedge into some relationship and
i just don't see any value in it okay
right um right the second thing is
you said he was sick does he have does
he struggle with addiction is he like
why do you say he's sick
because the manner in the way this
happened and how she found out it's like
basically he
contacted a prostitute but didn't have
to pay her i mean this is not someone he
had a
emotional connection with or worked with
and i mean it just came out of the blue
from what she understands and she was
saying you know mom that's sick that's
sick and i said yeah it is it is sick
he's sick he needs he needs help okay
um i feel like he's got some alcohol
dependency um
but that's not me to speak into you know
yeah um
if there's um
if there is addiction issues that are
making your daughter and your grandchild
unsafe it is yours to speak into okay so
the way i i frame this is not by your
hand but in your lap you didn't cause
any of this but your daughter called you
she brought you into this
and i'm gonna keep my grandchild safe
i'm gonna keep my daughter safe and if
she chooses to stay with this guy
then i'm gonna model what healthy
relationships look like and healthy
relationships do not have elephants in
rooms
they don't have secrets and they forgive
and like you mention they set bricks
down
and they lean in relationally
and so in my head i'm trying to think
through if this is my my daughter and
this happens with her husband
and she calls me and says well you keep
our baby i gotta go deal with my husband
and then i call her and say what's wrong
and she's weeping and now i'm brought
into this thing yes i'm gonna be pissed
off i'm gonna have to deal with my own
issues that's for me as a grown up to
deal with myself
right right um so i'm gonna go have my
friends in my community if i gotta reach
out to a council i'm gonna do that
myself
but when it comes to the relationship
um i would sit down with a young man
and say
i got brought into this so here we are
you hurt my daughter and you violated
our trust in our family you threw a
grenade here
and she's choosing to stay
which means you're a part of my life now
and that means i would probably do
something symbolic for a young man in
this situation like put it on a brick
and put tape on it like masking tape on
it and write it down cheat it on my
daughter
so he could see it
and say when she called me that night
i've been carrying this around because
it hurt me i lived through this in my
family and my all that right
and then this symbolic and from this
point forward i'm sitting it
down but here's what setting it down is
going to look like you and me are going
to have breakfast together or you and me
are going to like i'm going to lean into
this discomfort in the relationship and
i'll tell you if you tell them i feel
like every time we're in the same room
together there's some awkwardness
i'm the mother-in-law so i'll own it
but i want to get to know you
and we're going to spend some i want to
spend some time with you so i'm going to
reach out and i want to go do denny's
breakfast once a week or if they live
too far away then we're going to fill in
the blank
but i want him to see
he violated this thing
and but he's still going to be a part of
your life and so i'm going to lean in on
the healing part of it and you can do
the good parent thing
and say and if you ever hurt my daughter
again right you know i'm a person with
special skills they'll never find that
kind of thing yeah and you got a wink at
them but
um but i think there's something about
if you're interested in healing the
relationship and i get that from you
you're interested in healing this thing
you just don't know what's next
avoidance never works
right um secrets destroy families
unhad conversations destroy families now
your daughter could come to you and say
please god almighty do not mention
anything to him
don't talk to him don't bring it up it
can't happen um and i would push her on
that because she brought you into this
yeah and she might even say that i'm
never going to tell you again you can
say great great that's fine yeah you
told me about this one
yeah
and if he's gonna be in my house and i
want to invest in this relationship
because it's a part of your life
the sucky thing about boundaries is that
other people can use them too
right okay and they can use them to cut
you out just as much as you can say
here's what's gonna how my house is
gonna look like
i hope that isn't the case here
hopefully he is really repentant and
remorseful and is getting help that he
needs and also can be changed over time
by the love of his mother-in-law maybe
the first time somebody's reached out
and loved him
other than yeah
not in a romantic way
yeah yeah
yeah but holy smokes that'll be hard
right
man
yeah you know the your kids are young
the mama bear doesn't go away when they
become adults no no no there's some
great research on women and aggression
and especially with their kids
that
like men get the uh aggression stuff all
the time in the popular media but like
man
yeah mama bear dude that's for real
that's right that's for real
yeah yeah
so okay well this has been very helpful
how does that sound
good i i think um
yeah just sitting down with them and how
you approached it said hey i got brought
into this and and
like i said i don't want to guilt him or
shame him because i feel like he's
living enough of that right now um
he's very remorseful and i don't want to
throw darts at him
that would not be helpful at all so if
you're trying to help somebody not live
in shame
um
the only way to not live in shame is to
turn the lights on and have vulnerable
relationships
yeah
and yeah like is it bernie brown says
shame eat secrets for breakfast that's
what fuels shame
and so we're not gonna do this and the
path to freedom for him is some really
uncomfortable conversations with people
he hurt
and those people saying
and i see all of you and i still love
you
and i see all of you and now you got to
go to breakfast with me once a week
yeah
and it may be so awkward stay on the
line i'm gonna send you all of them
every pack of conversations with with
humans uh cards that we have
i'm gonna send you i don't know it's
awesome but here's the deal yeah you can
use them and you can say i got these
stupid cards for us to learn how to not
to learn you don't say anything just say
hey i got these cards and we're going to
go to breakfast until we go through
every one of these decks the ones for
work the ones for couples that's going
to get weird between me and you right
i think that would be a great way to get
to know this guy
yeah and yeah that would be yeah he may
hurt your daughter again and you can
tell him you got you got you've you've
played your card now okay yeah the next
time you hurt my daughter the next time
you violate our trust her trust as a
family that you
um
this is going to be a different
conversation than we have okay or my
boundaries will look different and
that's okay to have hard boundaries and
accountability and all that kind of
stuff i think that's really important
yeah yeah i don't think she would stay
if it happened again that's why when i
talked to her i explained to her your
scenario about the twin towers yeah
and it may be that he's not working five
hours from home anymore but part of that
is a new job and a part of that is new
all every everything's gotta be
different now and everything's gonna be
on the table they may have to move away
and go do live somewhere else
everything's on table now right when
you're rebuilding after infidelity
especially in a young marriage with a
young kid everything's different now and
great good cool awesome
the thing you can control in all that is
you and
even sitting with your daughter i would
recommend you sit down with her and have
a hard conversation um
to let her know that you'll be there for
her let her know she needs to get close
compadres and friends and community and
um
you need to have a conversation with
this guy and all that moving forward but
um
that's a tough i'm just thinking through
that man my blood boil's just thinking
about that and hopefully my daughter's
not married for a long long time and
hopefully she never experiences that um
but the dada tells me she might
and man
all of us have hard conversations
we have to look in the mirror before we
have and say well what's our goal of
this conversation and how can we bring
about both boundaries and
healing
man this guy's lucky to have you it's
his mother-in-law he won the lottery
we'll see you soon we'll be right back
hey what's up delona here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right let's take one more let's go
to janelle in seattle what's up janelle
hello dr john how are you i'm good how
are you
good
good i um i guess i i have a question um
i'll just start out um i i feel like my
husband and i are never on a team um i i
want to respect him and um and his
personality but i just i can't get past
the irresponsibility and the weight he
has me carry
um and i just i just don't know how to
deal with it it's been like eight years
and it just seems like we just can't
get on the same page i don't know what
to do
oh man i'm sorry
like just before we even dig in
like that's a
that's hard huh
yeah
yeah and and we've we've
talked about it argued about it um like
financially i've done the every dollar
app i have it all done all you have to
do is look at it and tell me where i
overspent
and he just he just doesn't care and i
just i just don't know what to do about
him like
please tell me like to stop spending or
something you know just have an opinion
and he just
he just doesn't so it's so they gave me
some notes on this jenna gave me some
notes um
says that y'all have been through
bankruptcy together
tell me about having to buy a house from
your parents
yeah yeah so um
when we got married it was like three
months after
um we got married i got hit with um
he told me that
he owed
like
tons of money to the irs
how much and i didn't
like 70 000. okay
and his mother was doing his books
and so
his books weren't very
well
done you know and so we did a refinance
on his house
and
i really didn't want to do it but i felt
like well we're married so
we i kind of had to
um
then he had a business on his own and um
found out that his business partner was
stealing money from him like ten
thousand dollars and the only reason we
found out is because i said you need to
go through
the books and make sure everything's
done
then
he
he ended up
he was drinking
a lot and so
i felt like i needed to move closer to
family
and so
after bankruptcy which
i was pretty devastated because
i don't
like that's not how i am yeah you know
what i mean so it was pretty
embarrassing and then we bought a house
um from my parents and um
it just
it just feels like my whole life is
based off of
his
decisions
and i just feel like i'm constantly
coping you know what i mean
you're getting dragged around
aimlessly
right so when you all have these
conversations he just blows them off
he gets really defensive
yeah and he um is really extreme and
then he like he'll say i'll just take
over everything and we'll just
move you know in to another state you
know we have kids so i'm not going to
drag them all through
this but so i'm trying to keep it stable
for your kids are getting dragged
through it
yeah there is no protecting them from
this they're absorbing every second of
it
i know and it's and it's hard yeah oh
yeah yeah no i know it's hard
um the als will stay together for them
or
um
my husband's an alcoholic he cheats on
me he's abusive he doesn't come home
he's bankrupt us he's not the
but the kids
right
yeah
they can often become a proxy for making
hard decisions or they become an excuse
for making hard decisions
right
have you and your husband sat down and
talked about divorce separate now
um there have been conversations um
we've gone to marriage counseling um
and it seems like
he's
it's only when it's it's only if i get
upset
that i'm taken seriously
um he he has right now he has a great
job and um we're financially okay now i
just feel like
um he still has me
carry these those bricks you know the
backpack when you say you've got to
carry stuff
what are you doing yeah what are you
what are you being forced to carry
um the finances i take care of all of
the bills um what happens if you say i'm
gonna stop
they won't get paid
okay so you you are married to a child
yeah okay
do you feel much the words you're using
sound much more maternal like you're his
yeah
and whenever i and this is a super
common thing so i want you to feel like
you're on an island by yourself but when
one or the other
spouse takes on more of a parental role
there's a different intimacy there
nobody wants to sleep with their son and
nobody wants to hook up with their mom
right so there's a it
it has a glitch in that relationship
and then
um that intimacy ripples through every
you're right so it just becomes a domino
that falls
um
have you when you've sat down with him
before i know you've probably had a
million conversations
uh what does he say about like
i don't want to be your mom anymore
he gets defensive
what does that mean
um
because that's what children do they get
mad they spit they throw things they
kick things yeah it's it's
it's pretty much slamming doors um
yelling you know um just about how he
can't do anything right
and
it's a child response
yeah yeah i guess so
um
it is it's grown up timber tantrum i'm
taking my ball and going home
fine we'll just move and we'll never
come shut up like right that's i mean as
a child
i need a grown-up to sit down across the
table with me and say are you gonna do
marriage with me anymore
yeah are we going to protect our kids
right
are we going to ever
um
fix the
sexual intimacy issues in our marriage
are we ever going to have some kind of
firm financial footing where we're on
the same page and we're on the same team
right you see what i'm saying like right
um that's a different
yeah it's hard it's hard to be married
to a child it's really hard to be
married to temper tantrums
and my guess is if he was on the phone
with me
um
he could probably point back to a few
places in his life when
a child had to take over and start
defending him from things oh yeah sure
and that child still
playing defense for him
and so that child kept him alive at one
point kept him safe at one point and now
that child is destroying everything
around him
right
yeah
and so the question is
is there a way that you can communicate
with him
have you sat down ever and said i need
like
normally when i talk to couples in this
situation the the conversations the deep
talks always happen on during fights
yeah
and
it feels like a great moment when his
finances are secure he's got a good job
things are okay to circle back and say
we need to have a big
we need to have a couple of hard
conversations
um i'd like to plan a half day would he
do that with you
he would um
i think it's for me it's the follow-up
you know like you said you were gonna do
like i've asked him like can we please
go over the finances once a month like
the beginning of the month please and
the every dollar is already done you can
see where all the money is spent and we
need to go over but you see you see
that's i would say that's one of the big
challenges because you've made every
dollar a math problem
yeah it's a different conversation to
say i don't feel safe
yeah i've told him that i feel
completely and totally alone without you
and when you don't participate it's
i can do the budget i'm a grown woman i
i can pay our bills
i feel like you would rather kick and
scream and throw a temper tantrum
then help your wife feel safe
yeah
that's a totally different conversation
and if he doesn't respond to that which
some
some marriage partners don't oh get over
yourself it's just a stupid budget
then the next response is i have to make
decisions about do i want to be married
to somebody who's not going to
participate in my marriage
right
because really you feel dragged around
it's the other way around you're
dragging him around
and i think you're tired
of carrying somebody in addition to your
kids in addition to your own things
um and you're probably by carrying him
probably carrying his family around and
all that other drama and you've got the
shame that you're carrying around but
all that you're tired
i am
it it is it's tired and there's just it
just seems like there's so much outside
drama that it's just that's right yeah
yeah and so a lot of this gets put on
um
on him
and he's a huge contributor make no
mistake
but my guess is there's a lot of just
mess
right there's just stuff
and so i think a valuable exercise would
be to sit down and say all right i'm
gonna write this stuff down what is
really on me
and you might find out that it's his
brother that comes over every wednesday
that always you know
like whatever like who knows what all
the things are once you start writing
them down but i'm gonna write these
things down
and you have to come up with your or
what statement and
an or what statement is couples who have
reached a point where like we need to
decide if we're going to stay married or
not we're going to have to decide if
we're going to keep dating or not
if these things don't change the or what
is then i'm gonna go
or if you know in your heart and mind i
will never leave i'm never gonna leave
then the alternative is to make peace
with where we are
and
there is a
often a blending of the two here's an
example in my own home okay
i talked about this a little bit on the
show i'm i'm a mess
i
have uh
i'm just kind of all over the place
and my wife is very list makey and very
on timey and
um very like things got to be done in
this way
and
i i
i've tried i can't operate in the world
that way and
i also know that
putting my shoes away
is a sign to my wife that i love her and
value her
yeah and so here's a compromise i got
home at 4 am the other day i didn't
unpack
i opened up my suitcase grabbed some
underwear out jumped in the shower and
got in bed and went to sleep i was
exhausted
okay you have no idea what it's like
trying to sleep on a plane next to kelly
who's listening to it her 80s medals
singing i'm just kidding she wasn't
singing um but
so she walks in
at 8 o'clock in the morning there's a
half open suitcase there's stuff thrown
everywhere
she's able to exhale and say
he got in late last night her first
thought is isn't
figures he's act like a child stupid
baby like her first thought is man he
must be exhausted
yeah and then when i got up and i
stumbled around got my coffee went out
did my little weird morning routine
then i could immediately say what's the
best way i can honor my wife right now
i need to get this crap cleaned up you
see what i'm saying it's about how can i
meet your needs and how can i meet my
needs that's how we find some peace in
the middle there it's not either or in
her perfect world you get home at 4am
you unpack you put everything where it
goes you start a load of laundry then
you go to bed right and then you make up
your bed
my perfect day is i'll unpack in a few
weeks when i'm leaving in town again
right so we're gonna find peace in the
middle all that happens because i'm
committed to meeting her needs and she's
committed to meeting mine
yeah
and if you can't have that with a
partner you've got to decide on my inner
am i out
can i any letters
what is it what are the effects on the
kids
do you know what i mean
the kids need well parents
yeah
the kids need well parents
and you're not okay and your husband's
not okay
and so any sort of pseudo performance to
try to make them
the reason why
this chaos continues
the times for me that we're staying
together for the kids works is if we're
staying together and we are so committed
to making this marriage thing work
yeah then a hundred percent figure it
out
yeah but when grenades are going off and
there's abuse in the home or there's
deception and infidelity and all these
things but we're standing together for
the kids
the kids are getting a ringside seat as
to what marriage and love look like
and they're getting a ringside seat to
what a beatdown exhausted mother looks
like
and a
lying deceiving
scheming husband looks like
or somebody who throws temper tantrums
oh that's what grown men do when someone
holds a mirror up to them they throw a
temper tantrum and they kick and scream
and take their ball and go
that's what they're getting
yeah
sometimes there's a gap and there's the
stay together or the divorce sometimes
uh terry reel talks about a 30 day
timeout
people are yelling and screaming 30 day
timeout
um and here's the he's actually got on
his website the rules of the 30-day
timeout
i got to get some space right and i'm
not saying that's the right thing for
you guys i'm saying there's an option
between we're all out of here overall
right
um
at some point your husband's gonna have
to decide is he in or is he out
yeah and that's it it's gotten to the
point where
we don't even
[Music]
like if we argue it's it's in our
bedroom and there's there's not a lot of
screaming except for like maybe once
every six months he might just go off
you know what i mean
um but it's i just feel more than
anything like you said just that beat
down like and that's that's some of that
comes from when you write down your
needs
one of the needs will be you will never
yell at me again
okay
you will never scream in this home
you will not raise your voice and kick
things in this house
and the moment y'all are in a
disagreement
every marriage has disagreements i had
one this morning every marriage has
disagreements
right
the moment a voice gets raised you can
say hold on hold on
i will not be talked to like that i will
be back later
and you head out the door
yeah
and he can kick and scream and yell
knock your lights out brother i'm not
going to be in the presence of this
okay that's what a boundary is
and for most children
they bang their heads up against
boundaries to see if they hold
and okay if they don't hold they keep
pushing until they find something in
their life that holds firm
and so you've probably told them a
million times i'm not doing their bills
anymore and then
five days later you're like i gotta pay
the bills
yeah there was there's like one time i
said can you take this to the post
office
and it sat in the truck that's very mine
and the follow-up is you always let us
you never do this i always i just need
one thing or the other is
when you didn't drop this off
the story i told myself is you don't
care about me
you don't care about the safety of our
kids you don't care about us having
water and
running water in our home
that's your behavior is a language and
your behavior told me you don't care
yeah
and it's not me yelling and screaming
that's that's me saying hey
here's what your behavior is telling me
and it makes me scared it makes me sad
and part of my
my values are i'm not gonna be in
relationships that make me scared or sad
yeah i get to choose that
yeah and any step forward with the child
if you say hey
this these things
i need you engaged at this level
um
or i'm i'm not interested in continuing
this relationship
a hundred percent expect the only
response that he seems to have which is
to act like a child
and oh you're gonna take my kids away
from me you're gonna take my
the same as if you tell your kids no you
cannot have fruity pebbles for dinner
again
oh you never let us do anything you're
the worst i hate it it's a child
response
and until your husband decides to
address the child who's been protecting
him his whole life
and to go back and deal with some of
that heavy trauma that he's experienced
i almost guarantee he has
and
come to terms with
being a participant in his home meaning
he's a participant in his family meaning
he's a participant in his own life
meaning he's worth being loved and he's
worth loving himself and he's worth
healing from some of that nonsense
and let me tell you it can happen i've
seen it happen it takes a lot of work
but it can happen it's hard
to be incredible
until he does that
he's gonna get back to a child
and children are really hard to be
married to we made laws and such
so sorry that you're exhausted i can
hear it on you i can hear it on you
we'll be thinking about you in your
journey
just try to
sit down and decide here's what i'm
worth here's what my values are here's
what i need in this relationship and
then have a conversation about what
that's going to look like moving forward
my hope is that he jumps and goes all in
says i hear you this time
let us know how that half day retreat
goes i'm fascinated to hear the
follow-up
and uh if he ever wants to tell him call
me i'd love to chat with him we'll be
right back
hey deloney here one of the things i
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if i do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as i'd love to i can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
i wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what i would say if you
and i were sitting down together
at a table looking for the next right
move for you to make in your
relationships or to help you live a more
whole and peaceful life as you read
through each section of this book i will
show you how to look and own the roads
from your past and head to the new roads
of a well life moving forward go to
johndaloni.com to get your copy today
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
a guy lives down the street here man one
of the greatest guys i've had a chance
to me is a lovely human being brad
paisley and the song is i'm gonna miss
her and it goes like this
well i love her
but i love to fish i spend all day out
on this lake and hell is all i catch
today she met me at the door said i
would have to choose if i hit that
fishing hole today she'd be packing all
her things and she'd be gone by noon
well i'm gonna miss her
when i get home but right now i'm on
this lakeshore and i'm sitting in the
sun i'm sure it'll hit me when i walk
through that door tonight yeah i'm gonna
miss her oh look you there i got a bite
[Music]
the best songwriters of my generation
brad paisley awesome hey so glad you're
with us we'll see you soon on the dr
john delaney show
[Music]